outre le noeud papillon pour vous
souhaiter une manière fois de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année dans la douceur et
la sérénité nous avons fait appel à
l'une de nos collaboratrices sylvie
marion qui entre autres passions dans la
vie
ces prises d'un amour fou pour lé
nounours c'est comme ça et au hasard de
son enquête elle s'est aperçue qu'elle
n'est pas la seule
bon
mais si vous aviez une hausse comme des
types certainement mal et a mûri j'ai un
souvenir
je me souviens même qu' il ya eu un
drame parce que un jour l'ours il est
passé dans des vieux cartons à la
poubelle alors que ma mère et moi on a
mis des années à s'en consoler
sort de l'ours père du disparu j'en ai
suis jamais voulu revoir après oui j'ai
un bras je serai bien qu'elle existe pas
encore de bien entendu il est bien
amorti et temaru il a les mêmes valeurs
j'ai racheté pour moi il est très le
personnage adulte 1 dans notre couple et
c'était moi l'enfant quoi et puis quand
il a perdu ses yeux
de son nez gelé démystifier je suivais
avec campagne et les jouets c'était ce
que je trouvais dans lé travail dans les
champs
toutefois des allumettes et tout ce que
je trouvais que pas des boîtes de
conserve ou moins amusés avec la s qui
avec d'autres enfants qui avaient des
ours
on veut y avait la rue par un village
mais dévoyée de langue na'vi est très
douce le nours les fans de l'ours
je me souviens pas avant et nounours et
pourquoi vous vous intéressez aux ours
messieurs chirac est ce que vous aviez
un ours quand vous étiez petit j'avais
un lapin foot lâche et n'hésite pas
d'ours sais pas d'où ça vient là mais le
cas je tenais beaucoup
il est très très gros est tout gris et
qu'est ce que vous lui racontiez mois
tous les ennuis systématiquement j'ai
l'impression que c'est votre ami nom qui
veut plus lours non gardé ensuite sept
tours jusqu'à maintenant
il est toujours sur mon bureau pour le
dessus de mon bureau voix voilà et
quelle qualité at il pour qu'on le garde
si longtemps c'est la trêve aux yeux je
dormais tous les jours avec lui et puis
quand je continue quand je partais
quelques pages les plus justes en
peluche et et jaune voyez que mes
souvenirs sont très précis et je pense
qu'il était un confident et qu'il était
est là et j'étais très fidèle c'était
toujours le même je me souviens très
bien pourquoi c'est un jouet important
pour vous ses parents de confier à lui
cette éminence puis c'est tout